back in our newsroom tonight we have the
results of a new eight news now emerson
college the hill poll now with the
general election just a few months away
campaigns are really gearing up for
their final push for votes as politics
now host john langler explains the big
races in nevada are only getting closer
[Music]
you've seen the money pouring in from
campaigns and political action
committees political ads they're on your
tv your social media everywhere else the
question our poll tried to find out are
they making a difference it's a
one-point race spencer kimball is
director at emerson college polling he's
as surprised as you may be with results
of our new glimpse at november's biggest
races we're seeing a high number of
undecideds and people voting for none of
the above 8 news now focused on two of
the campaigns getting the most attention
and the most money senate and governor
first in the race for senate our poll
shows a statistical dead heat republican
challenger adam laxalt leads with just
under 42 percent incumbent democrat
catherine cortez masto now trails with
just over 41 percent for the senator
that's a three percent drop from our
last poll in july undecided voters are
up from nine to 11 percent however the
poll also shows this unusual statistic
we asked which candidate do you think
will win not who do you want to win
senator cortez masto holds a 54-46
lead as opposed to like building up
their candidacy they're kind of taking
down the other candidacy and that's
what's keeping those numbers and it's
not moving voters from one candidate to
the other it's moving them more into
that undecided group if the race for
governor remains tight governor steve
sisolak leads by just .2 percent with a
three-point drop from july republican
challenger joe lombardo saw only a small
decrease both are now around 40 percent
however 52 percent of those polled still
think governor sisilak will win
re-election we think it's important not
just to hear how that person's voting
but what their circle of friends are
thinking the election itself is in 56
days john langler 8 news now